you know you can
do good in any organization it doesn't
matter if it's a company
a private sector government
a non-governmental or an activist
organization or your family i mean doing
good i think is what most people want to
do
and you just need to make sure that you
are very conscious and strategic about
it so any organization can do good even
businesses and especially businesses
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
hello and welcome to 20-minute leaders
today we're talking about impact and
sustainability with amalia adler the
vice president and global head of
environment social and governance esg at
teva pharmaceuticals amalia is a
seasoned global leader in esg healthcare
strategy and communications she's a
strategic planner executor and a
visionary manager who effectively drives
organizational change aligned with
business strategy
amalia established and leads global
health and environment social governance
esg unit in teva pharmaceuticals in tel
aviv israel and has recently led the
issuance of teva's 5 billion esg
sustainability linked bond the largest
such bond ever
amalia adler waxman welcome to 20 minute
leaders this is going to be so much fun
how are you today
i'm good how are you michael it's such a
pleasure to be here i i'm really honored
to have you here molly because
your your job really is to do good for
the world and
you've been working in such incredible
organizations
and and we'll go over them very shortly
but but what the tying not i think
throughout your career in the time
pattern
is the fact that everywhere you went
you've been helping the organizations
that you're at to do better and to be
more conscious about what they're doing
why they're doing it and how to then
both share it with the world but also
share it internally and figure out how
to do it properly today we talk all the
time about esg's and about impact
but you've been at it for for much
longer than than what we're just hearing
today in the news so amalia share with
me a little bit about yourself and a
little bit about your experiences and
then i'd love to hear how you see the
world of esgs and sustainability and
impact sort of make its way
you know since you're you've started
working on it
sure
it's so nice to you know recall
and go back to where it all started
personally and i think for many
organizations
um so i'm i'm from jerusalem originally
i now live in tel aviv
i have two daughters they're uh
big now and they work
and they study
and they're my greatest pride and
i i think that and i've lived uh
i've been around and about quite a bit
uh in in the world
and i think it's important to mention
that my career spanned
three continents i i've worked in israel
i've worked in
canada in geneva in switzerland in new
york then again in in the geneva lake
area in switzerland
so i think that a lot of
what i've done was really
defined by the places and opportunities
i i was able to
uh capture during those uh moves and the
moves were not something that i planned
it wasn't something that i woke up in
the morning and said oh i'm gonna
conquer the world
and i'm gonna have an international
career i was just uh
i i was lucky to have opportunities due
to some family circumstances was married
to
an israeli diplomat and that kind of
brought me very close to organizations
who
uh allowed me to help the world them do
good for the world
and then just to name a few the world
health organization the weizmann
institute
pfizer nestle to the pharmaceutical
pharmaceuticals today actively the vice
president and i love that they have a
vice president of of the esg of
environment social and governments
that's incredible
yes it's it's incredible i think uh not
just that we you know i'm i'm
vice president of esg i think it's
incredible
because it's a um
a real recognition and realization that
esg environment social government
governance or we i call it in two
different ways one is non-financial
performance which is kind of more dry
way of talking to this or the how
that are so integral and strategic to
the company in addition to the what and
to the financial performance
so i i think this is uh um
an involvement that you would see around
the world
but it's also very real where where i
see it and and within teva it's really
coming directly and straight from the
ceo
incredible
incredible take me back a little bit yes
i'll take you back and and the one thing
that i want to start with is that
just to say that you know you can
do good in any organization it doesn't
matter if it's a company
a private sector government
non-governmental or an activist
organization
or your family i mean doing good i think
is what most people want to do
and you just need to make sure that you
are very conscious and strategic about
it so any organization can do good even
businesses and especially businesses
and i'll i'll take you back not
a whole lot but well it may sound like
many years ago it's about 22 years ago
i to me it seems like yesterday and you
know globally it's not that much that
long ago
i
happened to come to switzerland
and i found a job at the world health
organization
and during those days
it was very interesting i was basically
looking for an interesting job
and and where i landed was in a
a department or a section a w chose that
that was dealing with non-communicable
diseases i didn't know anything about
health i didn't know what
non-communicable disease was
but what i did observe very early in the
days is that
the whole un system at the time started
to
look into social responsibility without
even understanding
that this is
the push that the un had been given to
companies
and the story goes that i came to look
into private public partnerships
with the private sector and who was not
overly friendly or collaborative with
the private sector
and the at at the heart of it was
how can we
influence companies
who are doing things that impact the
health of people
to be more responsible in the way they
do it without
even saying csr
and it was very interesting that exactly
at that time the secretary general of
the un was kofi annan
and he decided to create something that
was called the global compact he really
wanted to bring companies
closer to the agenda of the un
and from this actually what evolved was
a set of criteria of what it means to be
a good company
second what are the things that are most
important for the world this is the
millennium how the millennial
development goals evolved today we know
them as a sustainable development goals
it all started around 99 or 2000 exactly
when i came to who so
i did not plan a career in esg
i was doing something different yeah
what i was doing was exactly that wow
so you're sitting there continue please
so basically what we were trying to do
we were trying to see how we can work
with pharmaceuticals and food companies
to look into what they do and make sure
that they are well aware of their health
challenges and they address them
and there were some you know ups and
downs to this kind of uh conversation
and and
issues these were those were the days
where the first hiv medicines came
you know to the world they were very
expensive
there were activist
demonstrations i don't know some people
who lived at that time
would remember there were the seattle
demonstration
people really fought for making
medicines accessible for hiv to poor
people especially in africa where it was
a real
devastating
pandemic talking about pandemics
and
this was a big shift in how companies
now i'm in a fir at a pharmaceutical
company in between i was in a food
company but so it's interesting you know
how things in life can circle back where
sometimes you start it all
and this really created
a shift in the understanding
of companies that what they do has
sometimes positive sometimes negative
impact on society and on the environment
and there was
i think um
the direction of travel has really led
to where we are today globally with esg
and
somehow my career was you know just i
happened to be on on that path
incredible
so at what point
do you observe in in these 20-year span
do you see an inflection point
is it when the united nations
articulated that as part of the program
whereas the millennial goals and were
there different triggers that made you
feel that the world is shifting more
towards
the sustainability
and the development goals and in a
really practical way in the private
market
yeah i think
at least from my experience and maybe
this is where i was maybe things
happened before
but my observation is that yes this
this was a
you know a tipping point
at the by the way it's interesting i
think around that time the book tipping
point just came out so i think it indeed
was a tipping point from a global
a global perspective looking into
environmental and
social issues as is critical
and
in many ways i believe that over the
years different crises
unfortunately led to
you know a step up you know there is a
spiral and sometimes you know the spiral
goes down and then up you know it has
those jumps
so i think you know you if we look back
at those at the last 20 years
normally there was a step up after some
kind of a crisis
whether it's a social crisis like the
the 2008 you know
financial crisis which has led to
quite struck quite a lot of structural
changes including you know in the us
sometimes it's the spill you know of of
oil
that suddenly you know created more
attention for the environment
i think that kovid 19
you know if i think about all of those
incidents they may have been very
impactful on on a sector
or an area i think kovi 19
was really um
a critical turning point because i think
kovi 19 converged with a few a few
things
first of all
it was the pandemic it was access to
care access to health that everybody now
recognizes how important it is
i think it's the whole shutdown of the
world what happens to people to
employment
um
to how it impacts poverty i think it
you know how families are coping with it
what companies are doing to support
their employees to maintain the supply
it kind of it's not just a health crisis
it's a it's a pandemic that
amplified almost every aspect of life
and
we have to remember during covet
there were quite
scary
environmental issues crisis
terrible flames in california
drought
in california
uh i'm just talking about things that
might be closer to some of the audiences
but there were also you know equally
devastating cases in in other parts of
the world there were there was the
bushfire
uh you know in
flames in in australia which was
horrible
uh there were floods in germany so there
were so you know the environmental
issues
suddenly became very
pronounced not only that everybody
talked about how kovid
and and many other pandemics you know
emanated from animals and and you know
so so the environmental issues came up
and then
when all of this is happening we all
observed george floyd case you know
crisis in north america and suddenly you
know the whole issue of inclusion
and equity and and equity crosses covad
across this environment so i think
something in 2020
between covid george floyd this triangle
and the environment converged
and
on the background
of a lot of work that already happened
of investors already talking about esg
already looking at esg as a risk
management
opportunity
i think it actually made esg you know
one would think well all companies would
care is about just continuity of
business but actually you know it become
became very personal
and when things are personal we we have
a broader understanding of of the
society and we are also motivated to act
right what do you do today amalia what
does the vice president of esg at teva
do
so
um what what we do in esg is first of
all we work across the whole
organization
and esg is not just something that i do
or my team it's actually something
that's happening everywhere in the
company so so what is our value what we
basically do is that we help the company
understand
what
what is esg and what needs to be done
what are the stakeholder expectations
we do it through responding to a lot of
surveys and questions from
investors and customers that are kind of
very structured
and
we so we we look at all of this we
reflect it back or we put it in in the
face of everyone in the company
but then the other side of it is that we
bring everything that the company is
doing in those related issues and we
share it externally
so our role is to do reporting and
disclosure
and make sure that we understand what's
important for us as a company for our
stakeholders and shareholders and
customers
and we are responsible to understand
what's important for them
and make sure that we
are able to act upon it
and then this means that we gen we
improve disclosure we work with a lot of
teams at eva to create kpis
esg is measurable
and it will become even more so i said
at the beginning non-financial
performance so we are expected to
demonstrate performance over time
quantifiable
uh
so it's uh becoming
an area where you have to make sure that
you walk the talk and that you
actually have proof
for everything that you say so
this world is
really no not green washing in any way
you can't just green wash you have to
show proofs
on certain areas that you do and we are
responsible to making sure that we have
those internally and demonstrate them
externally in addition we are also
responsible for some of the health
related activities under the social
pillar
and the main issue for teva for instance
is access to medicine fund
to medicine
and what we are doing we are helping
drive programs that improve access to
vulnerable groups or groups that
have more difficulty getting access to
our medicines
amazing and so if we're looking now more
broadly at you know companies and esgs
and then where we're headed and you're
talking about performance and
measurability
that's something that it feels weird to
to talk about how do you how do you
measure
you know an impact in a quantifiable way
in a way that you know if the same
people that would ma that would be
measuring you know that your kpi or the
number of users or your annual rev you
know your your burn rate or your are
how do you go about strategically
quantifying impact
yeah
so
you
actually for some first of all we're all
learning you know what we need to
quantify and how to quantify it and not
everything is fully resolved
but i'll give you a few examples
for instance if you look at the
emissions
you know greenhouse gas emissions
those are quantifiable there are
methodologies
uh under something that's called
science-based targets initiative sbti
um there is the paris agreement and
there is a
a pathway whether it's one point
uh
one and a half degrees
uh you know
or well below two degrees
in terms of global warming and basically
there are some formulas and
methodologies and there is a way to
calculate your emissions and to report
on the reduction
so
if you look at water and waste and and
packaging
there are there are ways in
in some of those areas to measure
something and i'm saying something
because not all technologies not all
thresholds not all areas are
quantifiable in the sense that there may
be a way to quantify but we don't really
need know what we need to quantify there
is no regulation but there are more and
more there is more and more
understanding what you need to quantify
if we talk about access to medicine
uh we are looking we're trying to define
how many doses we provide to in through
our programs
by how much we increase the number of
doses that we provide
so because some of those areas are new
we can't always say what is good or what
is bad but we can demonstrate progress
and change which is quantifiable over
time
and that's and and when you make a
commitment that you will improve by
something
uh you can be judged whether you you
know you you stand behind what what
you're saying and
we just recently esteva we issued
um the largest ever sustainability
linked bond
this bond is basically a financial
instrument that you you go to
uh investors and and you raise uh you
raise the money so we this is a bond
that is linked to specific apis
that are measurable quantifiable
they have to be ambitious
they have to be linked to be linked to
your existing isd strategy so we issued
the largest ever of all industries
up until today bond of 5 billion dollars
um it's the first bond in our sector
that is has kpis that are both for
environment and access before us there
there was a bond not for so much money
but just for access and it's the first
generic bond um
we were the first company in israel that
issued such a bond so
through this bond you basically commit
financially to quantifiable kpis and
it's legally but you know it's it's
filed in the sec it's you really connect
a financial strategy with an esg
strategy
well yeah the work sounds incredible and
it sounds so impactful and meaningful
thank you very very much for coming and
sharing it with me
and i know that there's so many more
things that i wanted to talk to you
about but
20 minutes is not nearly enough to to
cover the impact you're doing so thank
you very very much nevertheless and it
was fantastic and stay safe and stay
healthy and continue making the world a
better place literally
thank you i hope the world will be and
health to everyone these days thank you
you